we went to a school and noted the
heights of a very large set of students
let's make a line to denote their
heights the heights recorded were in
meters the heights recorded were between
0.9 and 2.1 meters let's mark Heights
with intervals of zero point two meters
like 1.1 1.3 1.5 and so on if we plot
the number of students on this axis then
this is the data we get maximum at the
1.5 meters line equally distributed on
both sides of 1.5 which is the central
value this point is the maximum this
type of distribution is called normal
distribution and the data is distributed
equally on both sides of the central
value it is also referred to as the bell
curve as its shape resembles a bell but
is the data always normally distributed
does it always look symmetrical along
the central value line we look at an
example to understand this we wanted to
look at the graph of income distribution
per annum in a particular region say we
have the incomes on this line let the
income be in thousands of dollars the
range going from 10,000 to a $100,000
let's zoom in to look at the data
closely this is what we found maturity
of the people earn somewhere between
20,000 and $50,000 very few earn less
than $10,000 and very few earn more than
$100,000 here the central value is
around $50,000 look at the figure
closely we can see a long tail on the
right-hand side of the central value yes
it surely looks like a tail but there's
something important we need to know here
as the tail is on the positive side of
the central value we say that the
distribution is positively skewed it is
not equally distributed on both sides of
the central value this is kunis if we
compare it to the normal distribution
curve we can clearly see the difference
then what is negative skewness to
understand negative skewness
let's take a very simple example we have
the data of the Marx code by students in
an easy test let the Marx range from 20
to 80 we zoom in to understand the data
we gathered this time the distribution
looked something like this this is the
distribution of marks of students
majority of the students caught between
50 and 80 while the central value is 50
we see a tail here as well but this time
it lies on the left hand side of the
central value because it is skewed
towards the left hand side of the
central value we can say that the data
is negatively skewed now let's zoom out
to see all three distributions in the
normal distributions case the data is
distributed equally on both sides of the
central value in cases where the data is
skewed the distribution is not equal on
both sides if the tail is towards the
right side of the central value we say
that it's positively skewed and if it's
towards the left it's negatively skewed
you